[Music]
Selena Gomez stunning on the red carpet
at her first ever Cannes Film Festival
appearance she's there promoting her new
movie the dead don't die alongside Bill
Murray and Tilda Swinton flesh-eating
zombies don't choke it's really really
creepy I'm obsessed with zombies for
sure at a press conference for the flick
Selena got candid about the downsides of
social media though our world is going
through a lot obviously but I would say
social media has really been terrible
for my generation I understand that it's
amazing to use your platform but it does
scare me when you see how exposed that
these young girls and young boys are and
they're not really aware of the news or
anything going on and she didn't stop
there
it's a very it's it's just I don't want
to say selfish because that feels rude
but it is a I think it's dangerous for
sure I don't think people are getting
the right information sometimes
according to The Hollywood Reporter so
went on to add quote I think it's pretty
impossible to make it safe at this point
but acknowledges she's grateful for the
platform after all she has over a
hundred and fifty million Instagram
followers quote I don't do a lot of
pointless pictures for me I like to be
intentional with it it just scares me
last September she took a nearly four
month hiatus from posting and she's been
open about social media with et in the
past I think that for me I'm really big
on vulnerability I think people are
really scared to be honest with
themselves and strength has looked upon
us
oh I'm strong I don't need anything I
can't hate I can handle everything and
that's just not the truth and I think
kids especially with social media
sometimes they just
foster phobic and I don't think their
voice is actually being heard and I
think that's the message I want I want
people to know that every every single
life is valuable that their voice can be
heard and that there are people who are
willing to be there for them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]